share your screen yes
yes i hope everyone can
see my screen we can see your screen yes
and uh even now all right so so we are
ready to go i'll do a brief introduction
hi myra thank you for joining us so
mayor nike has
uh started his work sort of in his phd
times on static
analysis and he was a pioneer in
applying machine learning to
that field of formal methods or making
static analysis better
but then later he started applying
sort of machine learning deep learning
to program synthesis and this will be
the subject of
today's talk thank you for joining us i
understood that you just came from your
class i'm glad you could find time to
join us
yes uh thanks russ it's a pleasure to be
here
so i'll be talking about in our
experience applying
machine learning and more specifically
deep learning
uh to program synthesis uh this is joint
work with
many folks over the last three years
um and i'll be touching upon some
works more than others i've just listed
all the main authors in this
collaboration
okay so let me begin with a brief
background
so the kind of synthesis
framework that i'll be focusing on
throughout this talk the talk is um
called sieges so counter example guided
inductive synthesis
um which began in fact with uh ras and
his phd student
armando at that time
so in this framework you have
two components a synthesizer and a
verifier
so the synthesizer takes a high level
specification
of the program you'd like to synthesize
and produces um
you know sequence candidate programs
which
are verifier confirms as either the
desired program
or gives feedback in the form of say
counter examples
so in this framework we can express
a variety of different synthesis tasks
and i'm only going to talk about the the
tasks here that we have applied
uh uh our methodology to
uh so we'll begin with um
loop invariant generation so in this
case
um the specification is uh
um a verification condition
um a logic formula which encodes the
program that you see here on the left
along with the assertion um
and this the goal of the synthesizer is
to
come up with an expression like the one
you see at the bottom left um
using a syntactic specification which is
shown at the top
right so that's the grammar of
invariants that we'd like to
synthesize and the verifier can be an
smt solver such as z3
okay
another example
is constraint solving so in this case
you have a different formulation of the
same
problem i showed on the previous slide
except that now instead of a smt solver
we might want to use a chc solver
and the input looks very different this
time
it is still a verification condition but
now these are all
uh horn constraints and the output
grammar
is still the same um and here's an
example
output which a chc solver like spacer
would
accept as a candidate
for the predicate itp that you see here
so idp is a binary relation over
integers
and the goal is to synthesize a program
that conforms to this grammar
and furthermore that a chc solver
can conclude
is makes this formula valid
okay so um
yet another application and the one
which i'll focus primarily throughout
this talk
it comes from the ai domain
it's called referring expression
generation it was originally proposed in
2014 uh by the paper i've listed at the
bottom
uh titled refer it game
and the idea here is that
it is too challenging for today's ai
architectures to describe let's say a
scene
and so there's a simple challenge which
is
if we refer to a certain object in the
scene at least then can we
can we name that object
so it's a more local task and then the
task was further simplified by
folks at stanford who designed the
clever data set
that some of you might have heard of
where to further reduce the noise
they went from real world images to
synthetic images like the one you see
here
nevertheless this is still a very
challenging task even though
you see only synthetic objects in this
scene and the goal
is to uniquely identify
a particular object in this case
the object label g
um the reason this task can be very
challenging is
uh you might need logical reasoning
in order to come up with an expression
that uniquely
names this target object
so here the specification is you are
given
an image along with a desired output
which is
the object that is labeled in this case
g
you're given a grammar for the program
we'd like to synthesize
in this case it is a conjunction of
clauses of the form you see here um
you can for example uh say
uh talk about the colors of objects or
their shapes or their materials and
their relative positions
and so on
and in this case the verifier can be um
something like a data log solver um
where you can execute um these
relational programs and check
whether they produce the desired object
as the value of a distinguished variable
which i will call
var0 okay so in summary here the goal is
come up with a
a single rule data log program
um where which when evaluated on
a relational representation of objects
in this image
uh will uh produce a single
uh object as the value of
var0 and that object should be the one
that is
labeled in the specification in this
case
g
so um what is the problem with applying
conventional search techniques right
um and i've listed a few of them here um
the main ones uh the syntax guided
enumeration where you
can enumerate these candidate programs
according to
uh the syntax of
the programs to be synthesized a classic
example is
uh e-solver
there are other approaches for example
there's an approach that we have dubbed
example guided enumeration
and you already see some some uh
instantiations in the literature such as
flash fill and flash relate
which um which look for patterns in the
in the input
data in order to guess the candidate
programs
we have a paper coming up at pldi called
example guided
synthesis egs which
uh shows how to for example generate uh
relational programs uh like sql queries
uh using this idea as well
and then there's evolutionary or
stochastic and genetic algorithms um
examples being stoke which
is a super optimizer
for optimizing small
pieces of code into assembly
um there are many optimizations in the
literature to speed up
this search i've listed some of them
here such as
indistinguishability which is used in
e-solver just work on probabilistic
models to
to prioritize the search based on
likelihood
of the programs
and and so on
so we set out to understand what are
some
desirable features of a search technique
that we'd like to have and we came up
with these five
features the first is it should be easy
to design
you know extend the search algorithm
right for example we should be able to
go from a linear invariant generator to
a non-linear invariant one by simply
changing the grammar
of the programs of the invariant right
uh another desirable feature of course
is scalability
um yet another which is somewhat
overlooked in the literature
is that the programs should be natural
or they should
have some measure of quality okay
and i can give an example here if you
look at the
the software verification competition
it is acceptable or even the saiges
competition for example
it's okay to produce programs that are
very unnatural as long as they satisfy
the verifier
um furthermore the last two are very
uh relevant to machine learning uh which
is
uh we want the search to become a
smarter
uh over time uh across different
instances
and also a related aspect is we would
like it to
be able to adapt
its search strategy to new instances
okay so learning across different
instances means avoiding mistakes
from the past and and it might be that
new instances could be
very different from those you have seen
in the past and so we'd like the search
to
adapt itself
so uh we can look at uh what has been
done
in uh machine learning in particular in
reinforcement learning
so there have been a lot of successes um
in the context of
uh strategy game playing so you've heard
of for example
alphago and and so on um
for chess go and and many other games
right um in this case uh however the
the rules for strategy games are fairly
simple
and the environment
gives scores based on the
outcome of applying these rules
whereas in program synthesis we are
given
a a syntactic specification which is the
grammar
of the program to be synthesized and a
semantic
uh specification which is uh a verifier
such as z3 or spacer or a data log
solver as i just showed
so these differences um pose new
challenges
uh both in terms of how to uh
represent a given program synthesis
instance and in terms of how to uh
conduct the search okay
so in particular
if you think about the state
that you'd like to represent in the case
of games
it is typically a 2d
matrix of lopix cells uh and the
the neural architectures are well known
for example convolutional networks and
so on
but for programs there's much richer
structure
um and um one might wonder what is the
best
uh neural architecture and
uh we have come up with uh one which is
uh uh called graph neural networks
um that was um
discovered by um you know
others in the past so we have just
applied graph neural networks to this
problem
um but there are many other
architectures as i'll talk about later
for example transformer models
viewing a program as a set of paths and
so on that are also
relevant here there are also challenges
in terms of reinforcement learning so
for games the space of actions is fixed
and finite
and there is often
a smooth reward that you can come up
with
in order to learn um the policy
efficiently
whereas for programs you have a context
free grammar to guide
the search and the reward can be
extremely sparse
so typically a solver will only say yes
or no
when a candidate program is proposed
okay
it typically has more information but
you converting that into a smooth
reward is can be challenging
so here's an approach that we have come
up with
and in fact we have um
[Music]
infrastructure that is open source that
you can use to
to cast your
favorite problem in this setting as well
um
so the idea here is um to provide a way
to
to represent your
specifications symbolically and that
becomes the state
um then we have a neural network which
is the synthesizer
that will perform a series of actions
um and thereby producing a series of
partial programs
that can be executed by
the environment in this case verifier
and what we do next is we both
update the state and we uh give a reward
to the neural
network um and the process repeats
okay so if you squint at this figure you
will see the sieges
loop over here
so what i'm going to do is take a short
detour from my slides and show you
a demo before proceeding further
so you can go to this website go to in
dot org
um and try out some of these examples
let me pick one of them here so you see
this is a program like the one i showed
earlier
it is converted into this task
so here's the specification verification
condition
and here's the grammar of
the looping variants we'd like to
generate
and what we do is we convert this
verification condition into a graph
because we are going to need this
symbolic representation
um for our
reinforcement learning framework
so this is again for the user to design
okay so um we have come up with a
particular way to
encode vc's into graphs and i'll
talk about more about that shortly
and with these inputs you can
run the framework and it's starting from
scratch here with all the weights
untrained
and what you'll see after a while is a
candidate
in variant you might say that this is
unnatural in many ways but
this is purely because of certain
limitations
that are very easy to do post-processing
or regularizing and so on
and what you have seen here is the
number of iterations of the cds loop so
there were 17 calls to
the verifier in this case
and you can also see a larger number of
tests for the pre
and post condition checks and the
inductive invariant check
and what you see here is um the result
of partial programs being generated so
in this even though there were only 17
iterations of the sieges
loop there were many more uh
checks of partial programs that were
needed to
get a smooth reward okay
you can also use the same framework for
in this case
i'm showing you chc formally
and and here's the graph encoding this
time it's different than what i showed
earlier
the grammar is still the same but you
could use a different grammar if you
wanted
and in this case now the once again the
framework is running but
using uh a chc solver
instead of an smp solver
okay hopefully it will
converge soon enough before i return to
my slides
please feel free to ask any questions
while
we let it finish
okay so here we have the final
expression in this case you know z3
happens to have a chc
solver as well so there were nine calls
made
so anyway the the framework is general
enough
what i showed you in fact was exactly
the same underlying neural architecture
in both of these cases
[Music]
and that goes back to
one of the the nice things about this
approach which is it's very easy to
to to adapt it to different tasks
without having to provide any hand
engineered heuristics and so on
so in the rest of my talk i'm just going
to go over
you know one particular example which is
the referred example
let us start with the symbolic
representation right so how do we
provide this representation i am going
to
skip some of this in the interest of
time
the point here is we want to go from
this rich structured
representation of programs to
um an embedding right a vector
of reals um and as i said earlier we use
a graph neural network for this purpose
okay um i won't have time to go into
what graph neural networks are
um but the idea intuitively is um
that doesn't the the
embedding here is uh essentially
some combination of the embeddings of
the nodes in the graph
and those node embeddings are computed
by
message passing so there are features
about the node itself but then
the more you iterate over this embedding
each node now has information about
the nodes farther and farther away from
it in the graph
so it has more and more context
information
since we did this work there has been
the emergence of transformer models so
what i said here
is not necessarily true today and in
fact we ourselves are
working with not just graph neural
networks but also trying out
these sequential models the transformer
models
and there's work between these two
extremes as well so instead of treating
programs as a sequence of tokens or as a
graph
you can have representations which treat
programs as a set of paths for example a
lot of work by
iran yahoo falls in that category
and there are interesting tradeoffs in
these different
representations but all of this work is
all
about graph neural networks
in the case of um the referred problem
uh the
the representation is relatively simpler
once again you see
the objects in the scene being
represented by
various nodes and their types of these
nodes
along with nodes for the attributes and
relationships between them and so on
okay so i'm not going to go too much
into the detail but
this is one of the limitations of this
approach which is you still have to
design
the symbolic representation
but once you have that much of the
the architecture is automated
right and i'm just going to show a run
of this loop
next so the goal of the neural network
at each step is to
select uh an action
in this grammar right so pick a
production rule um
in in the case of the refereed problem
it is to pick clauses
right and uh they are picked according
to the representation of the
specification
and the grammar that is given so both uh
this semantic and the syntactic parts of
the
task and let us say
the first clause picked is that the
target object should be
a gray colored object okay so this is a
candidate program that is generated
we then execute this program using the
verifier
there are many ways to design the reward
and this is the only other part that is
needs to be manually designed besides
the symbolic representation
in this case it turned out to be that a
very sparse reward
is good enough we did try richer
smoother rewards but they didn't give
much benefit
over the simple approach where if the
target variable variable 0 denotes
exactly
the object of interest in this case g
then 1
otherwise 0 so in this particular case
we get
0 reward because var 0
denotes every gray object in the scene
and you can see
that there's c h and g right
so what we do next is we update
the state uh based on uh the output of
the current program
so var0 now points to c h or g
okay so one thing you notice here
is that by representing the state in
this manner
we are capturing uh
an infinite set of different programs
that all
evaluate var0 to these
three objects okay and the same holds
for bar one and bar two and so on
which i'm not showing here
and then we simply repeat so the next
clause um
um is uh that
var zero is in front of bar one and then
uh the next clause is that var1 is a
brown object
right and at that point we have um
gotten a reward of one because var0
points to
the the unique desired object g
okay so
we evaluated this approach on the clever
data set which i mentioned
earlier and we also created a diagnostic
data set which is even more
complex in terms of reasoning i've shown
two such
examples here the first class is three
one one
one one which means that we have seven
objects out of which
three are of the same kind in this case
a b and g
and then there's a different kind of
object for each of the remaining four
and the six one category is even harder
you see six out of the seven objects are
of the same kind
and only one is different and
what is hard about these compared to
clever is that
it can take fairly complex programs to
be synthesized in order to uniquely
label designate a certain desired object
okay so here's a qualitative result
in this case we are looking at the
category 3 1
1 1 1 where a b and c are three objects
of the same kind
and d e f g are all different
and turns out that if you want to
uniquely refer to the object
a here then you need a 10 clause
program okay and what is that program
saying it is saying that
the object being referred to is the
large blue cube
to the left of the left of
a large rubber blue cube okay and the
reason to say that
that this is a rubber cube is because at
the other extreme
g is a is a metal cube okay
so um so these are fairly challenging
tasks and
you can think of them as in two
different categories
the first three which is three one one
one one
four one one one and five one one are
relatively easier than
the remaining three six one five two and
four three
and indeed you see that our approach
does uh
fairly well it can um within the
the timeout of 200 rollouts it can solve
the vast majority
of these although it does suffer a bit
for these three harder categories but
you see that
other approaches do much worse for
example
enumerative synthesis approach um
does fairly poorly on these three
categories
and even not so well on the first three
metal is our own prior work which uses
exactly the same architecture that i
showed you
but with a lesser domain specific
optimizations
um and even and while that does better
than the
hand engineered enumerative synthesis it
still doesn't come
close to the approach that i presented
okay so uh with that i'm i'm done i'll
just
talk about three uh future challenges
here
for those of you interested in uh you
know learning from
the lessons that we obtained the first i
believe is in order for
this approach to become
really practical we need a tighter
integration between the neural
synthesizer and a symbolic solver so for
example let's work on
differentiable fat solvers and so on um
we are ourselves working on
differentiable data log and so on um
so this would enable the approach to be
even more uh
efficient uh instead of using the
symbolic solver just as a black box
another that we another thing that we
fail to do
despite trying hard is it seems to be a
waste to
not use uh hand engineered
heuristics that work well for existing
symbolic solvers for example the
indistinguishability optimization from
each solver we were not able to
incorporate this into a neural
architecture
but this is worth trying in future
and lastly there are two parts here
which are not so
systematic which is how to design the
symbolic representation
and the reward mechanism and i believe
program synthesis itself has a role to
play
in in these two
aspects okay so with that i'll stop and
i'll be happy to take
any questions thank you mayor
uh let's say we do have time for one
question
if we want to finish more lesson time
rameen uh
would you like yeah i have a question
thank you so much for the great talk so
what's what's your take on the
i was wondering like um the work of josh
tenenbaum of clever two
have you have you guys looked into those
kind of video processing with this
approach no we haven't uh
yeah because you know like clever i
think it's called cleverer too
and this is like very similar kind of um
symbolic reasoning
while for example an object is moving
inside an environment
right okay so i was wondering like
would this technique like can you extend
this technique
to those kind of scenarios like symbolic
reasoning
yes so so this is something we are
working on currently okay which is um
uh you know allowing the user to express
um you know uh more knowledge
using symbolic constraints but then
you know determining uh but keeping them
in a logic that is
amenable to uh automatic uh
differentiation so we are currently
doing this
for a logic called data log which allows
recursion
um but then doesn't have sort of the
some of the fancier aspects of say smp
solvers
cool so so yes that is something we
would like to get to eventually
but we are not there yet great thank you
thank you mayor again and with that we'd
like to
speak to our uh last but not least
speaker
kevin ellis and
mayor nicely